du cinéma pour terminer avec la belle
reconversion de notre fameux loulou
révélé au grand public par la série un
gars une fille diffusé sur notre antenne
jean dujardin est aujourd'hui un acteur
très demandée au cinéma succès populaire
avec brice de nice et aujourd'hui il y
incarne un james bond à la française
dans oss 117
le tournage se déroule actuellement à
rabat au maroc pascal deschamps et
nadine picard y était en 1949 débarquer
dans les librairies oss 117
hubert bonisseur de la bath agents
secrets de son état deux cent soixante
cinq romans huit films plus tard le
revoilà sous les traits de jean dujardin
smoking cheveux gominés sourire
conquérant
le nouveau chouchou du box office s'est
glissé avec plaisir dans la peau de ce
james bond à la française qui manie
aussi bien le crochet du gauche que le
passing shot votre chambre vous combien
tel 6 10 mois est très bien cependant je
dois vous avouer que j'ai trouvé un
petit peu de désordre
il évalue une souris sur le lit et un
kafir d'emploi car j'ai ma petite forme
est là moi je dirais que c'est un peu de
jeunes et beaucoup de conneries c'est
vrai car nous sommes évidemment dans une
comédie dans le caire nid d'espions dont
l'action se déroule en 1955
notre nouvel oss doit déjouer un complot
anti nasser si l'on retrouve l'esprit
des films d'espionnage on est plutôt
dans le décalage jean dujardin avait
reçu le scénario de ss bien avant le
succès les brice de nice s'il croule
aujourd'hui sous les propositions venues
de tout le cinéma français
il n'a pourtant pas la grosse tête c'est
super un succès évidemment c'est génial
ça met encore plus en confiance ça donne
envie de faire encore plus de choses ça
motive beaucoup plus je sais qu'il ya
peut-être bout de canon qui seront rivés
sur moi c'est pas important je je
m'écoute je me fais confiance pour
l'instant et technicolor et images
léchées l'esthétique du film rappelle
l'homme qui en savait trop d'hitchcock
un savoureux mélange entre films
d'époque et comédie à savourer au
printemps 2006 du metropolitan
voilà c'est à la fin de ce journal